we're definitely a close family like
more than probably normal the
Kardashians aren't gonna let a little
thing like quarantine get in the way of
celebrating a family member's birthday
oh the whole Kardashian crew got
together for an outdoor bash to
celebrate Scott Disick's 37th birthday
on Tuesday Kylie Jenner shared this pic
with a birthday boy on her instace story
writing yesterday celebrating let the
Lord be with you
also in attendance Kourtney Kardashian
Scott's ex and the mom of his three
kiddos I love it she posted this pic to
Instagram posing it up with her little
sis in a burnt orange silk shirt dress
oh and did you notice the ice cream
truck in the background that reads
please wash your hands what a time to be
alive
anyway the 22 year old makeup mogul also
shared this snap with her two-year-old
daughter stormy who honestly might have
had the most fun of anyone at the soiree
hanging out with her cousins yeah that's
Khloe's two-year-old daughter true
sharing a snack with stormy it's such a
beautiful thing khlo posted a heartfelt
birthday tribute to Scott on Instagram
calling him a great brother and adding
forever family I love you long time
Koko also shared these pics of her baby
girl at Scott's party wearing an
oversized shirt that reads Disick
quarantine Club God I just think how we
had fun and Kim's kiddos they were there
too that's true holding two-year-old
Chicago's hand and that Psalm inside a
big white bounce house it's always so
much fun while Scott didn't share any
pics from the big bday event he did
share a pic of his birthday present from
Kris Jenner a mountain bike the birthday
bash comes after Scott and quartz family
getaway to Utah with their three kids
last weekend where they went horseback
riding roasted marshmallows by the fire
and hung out by the pool but it hasn't
been all bay caves and birthday bashes
for the reality star I think you just
got to figure out really what's
important to you at the end of the day
according to multiple reports Scott and
his girlfriend of three years
Sophia Ricci have called it quits and
earlier this month ET learn that Scott
had recently checked himself in and out
of a Colorado rehab facility at the time
a source told ET that both Sophia and
Kourt were big proponents of Scott
seeking treatment again ET source added
that Scott has struggled with these
issues for a while and although he was
previously doing well it was time for
him to get help again
there was definitely a process when et
sat down with Scott last year he opened
up about what matters most through the
ups and downs I mean there's so many
different things that could pull you in
different directions and you could look
online and Instagram social meeting all
these things but at the end of the day I
mean you just want to be happy you want
to be content you want to be comfortable
[Music]